[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i want to get to mike florio kind enough
to join us on uh short notice and his
new book by the way is a must play
makers comes out march 15th can be
purchased both online wherever books are
sold mike sent me an advanced copy and
there's a lot of good stuff in there
didn't autograph it but there's a lot of
good stuff in there mike joins us now no
autograph news you are fake news i
autographed it oh you signed it oh you
did yeah you haven't even opened it no i
did i open it to the actual chapters not
the first couple of pages the open up
the cover okay and there's a lovely
inscription it may bring a tear to your
eye probably won't but i did sign it
paulie do you know where i have florio's
book
paul's going to look for it okay where
do you keep the garbage
i i i think do you got it right there
paulie
[Laughter]
no i can't i got it right here it's
really close to me
okay let's see what it says here's mike
florio's playmakers how the nfl really
works and it doesn't dp thanks for your
friendship and support over the years
mike florio
well that's not really you know i know
cheers
but i did sign it how about thank you
for my career i never would have had
this career without you dan
that's true that's true but i've i've
already told you that separately so i
need to come up with something different
all right thank you okay thank you for
my career help me understand back now
help me understand
the sean mcvay situation and does it
affect kevin o'connor is it real
there it would affect kevin o'connell
taking the vikings job well you know we
learned four years ago
in a super bowl that was played in the
stadium where the vikings play their
home games that none of this stuff's
ever done until it's done and i keep
seeing reports about what the vikings
are going to do
i'm waiting for the report that it's
done i want to see
the signature from kevin o'connell on
the last page of the contract and until
it happens
we saw mcdaniel's joke the colts now
there's no real reason right now to
think it's going to happen but if stan
cronkie's working behind the scenes he's
the owner of the rams obviously and he's
like hey sean what are you going to do i
think it's too early for the sean
mcveigh situation to come to a head
where stan kroenke would have to pivot
to kevin o'connell and he's got raheem
morris the defensive coordinator if
mcveigh does leave so it's not as
critical as it would be but if mcvay
would exit like today which no one
thinks that's going to happen
you'd have to wonder whether or not
cronkite would trump would want to try
to keep kevin o'connell but i get the
impression mcveigh is kind of sitting
back and waiting to see if one of these
networks makes him an offer that either
he can't refuse or that he can't resist
taking to cronky and saying hey they're
going to pay me 15 million
uh you're paying me x are you going to
pay me more or not and i think that's
fair game i think mcveigh's in a great
spot now somebody's either going to make
him a a a
an offer that he says wow okay i'm
leaving for espn or wherever or cronky's
going to pay him either way he's going
to get paid
okay so aaron donald is that a leverage
play as well it could be he's due to
make 55 million over the next three
years about 18 million in change he puts
a lot of himself into his offseason
preparation la is a long way away from
pittsburgh he's a pittsburgh guy and hey
having flown from pittsburgh to l.a and
la to pittsburgh nine days apart it's
like two different worlds and he's out
there for five months out of the year
and i think that's wearing on him after
eight years so
you want to make it worth his while you
know he's currently doing it for 18
million 9 million under the top of the
market for a defensive lineman maybe
that gets his attention and gets him to
do it again but i really do think he's
seriously considering calling it quits
while he's at the pinnacle of the
profession after eight years and after
putting a lot of himself into his game i
was also wondering about odell beckham
jr with this knee injury knee surgery
uh at at some point does he start to
look at
what's next could you see him in the
media could you see him as a you know a
studio analyst here and and what would
be that value
well i mean he always brings value
because of who he is but as you know at
some point you have to actually do the
job and there are plenty of former
players who become analysts
and they don't really become analysts
they they you have to become a fan of
the game you have to think like a fan of
things you have to follow the sport like
a fan follows the sport or you quickly
lose relevance you quickly make no sense
it can't just be well this is what we
did this is what i did this is what you
know this is what i know from when i
played you've got to be a true student
of the game and i don't know that he
cares about football enough to make that
pivot maybe he does maybe he does but
you're right dan look
same acl torn twice
and
michael david smith from pft pointed out
yesterday that when he did it the last
time it was like 11 months before he was
cleared to play again he'll miss all of
the season at least all of the regular
season if if he has that same trajectory
with the same injury to the same knee i
mean that was that was heartbreaking for
him
he could have been the mvp of the game
the way he was playing the rams lost the
air out of the balloon when he got
injured and they almost didn't get it
back in time
we're talking to mike florio pro
football talk live co-host with chris
sims you can watch that on peacock i
know that matthew stafford is a hall of
famer was a big topic i think we ran out
of topics so it's like matthew stafford
a hall of famer question mark but i have
to give matthew stafford credit for two
things megatron's season that was the
greatest season we had seen by a wide
receiver and now cooper cubs which is
the greatest uh receiving year that
we've ever had
it doesn't feel like he gets any credit
of that you're like oh that's right he
was uh calvin johnson's quarterback
where do you stand with matthew stafford
right now
well
matthew stafford suffered through 12
seasons in detroit where he was
pretty much alone but for calvin johnson
and they did have in dominic and sue for
a while but it's a dysfunctional
organization
and they never were able to put together
a consistent winner now there have been
times where i was concerned that he
wasn't as forceful from a personality
standpoint as a peyton manning or tom
brady would be and he kind of tolerated
not being part of a great team maybe he
should have forced himself out of that
situation earlier but he can make all
the throws i mean you've seen the video
the no look throw to cooper cup he's
always been like that he was patrick
mahomes before we we learned about
patrick mahomes the guy's got incredible
arm talent and when you look at the
all-time statistics he's already 12th
in passing yardage 12th in passing
touchdowns and he just turned 34 last
week so this whole idea of is here a
hall of famer to me it's ridiculous
because he's got
five more years left i don't know how
long he's going to play there's many
chapters left in this book he could win
another super bowl if he gets another
super bowl he's clearly a hall of famer
uh he could finish in the top five of
passing yardage of course that puts you
clearly in the discussion so
um and and i respect the fact that you
know he's not a guy who's very
demonstrative we don't get a lot of
videos of him chewing people out on the
sideline we don't get a lot of hot take
reports about whether he's selfish or
immature there isn't that kind of stuff
and
you know it's hard to stand out if
you're not that way
but his play does all the talking for
him and people are starting to
appreciate it more now that he's with a
better team what should we keep an eye
on with deshaun watson's offseason
well
we've been expecting or hoping or
waiting for some sort of resolution as
to the criminal probe the prosecution
potential prosecution grand jury work
was supposed to be done the end of
january now that we're clear of the
super bowl i need to go back and see
where that stands you got 22 lawsuits
that are moving forward now that the
super bowl's over
he can be questioned under oath by tony
busby who represents the 22 individuals
and
uh you know the problem is
it's so obvious he needs to put these
cases behind him to continue his career
that that gives tony busby more leverage
when it's time to negotiate a settlement
they had 18 of these 22 cases ready to
work out back in late october so he
could have been traded to the dolphins
there were four holdouts the value of
that case keeps going up and up and up
if you know he's got to settle these in
order to get back to the nfl so at some
point they just have to sit down and
work this out he needs to work out
satisfactorily to the individuals who
claim they were victimized by watson
something that allows him to put it
behind him but uh you know the problem
then is the quarterback carousel is
gonna start spinning
seats are gonna get filled
and and maybe the teams he wants to go
to
will have moved on so it's gonna it's
gonna be a challenge for them to get
this taken care of the book is
playmakers it's uh mike florio's book
march 15th can be purchased online
wherever books are sold thank you mike
thanks dad
employer will autograph it for you he'll
come to your house and autograph it for
you